whoa you hear that that that little oh
my god
oh we hear it loud and clear that's the
sound of Billy Eilish the 18 year old
superstar has had a huge year leading up
to the 2020 Grammy Awards where she's up
for six awards and get this she's the
youngest artist ever to sweet noms in
the big four categories best album song
record and best new artist what's like I
don't even know
join us as et takes a walk down Billy
memory lane and celebrates her road to
the 2020 Grammys if everyone died right
now right here and I was just here if I
had been working for something I didn't
want then I'd be stuck with this thing I
didn't want and I just be like chilling
like wow what am i doing now so make
every second count make every make every
second like everyone's dead you know I'm
saying that was Billy in March dropping
serious wisdom just two weeks before
releasing her debut album when we all
fall asleep where do we go so much
talent at such a young age do you feel
older than you are
when I started this and I was 13 I was
I'd never been older than that you know
so I wasn't thinking like oh my god I'm
so young because you're doing it you're
doing what you're doing it doesn't you
know you're not thinking like oh my god
I'm so young to be doing this et was
with Billy at her album release party in
LA it's funny because sometimes you
dream about something and you might
write it down you might tell people and
be like this is what I want you know in
my wildest dream and then I did that and
here all sorts of dreams came true for
Billy as she said she was ready for
world domination this album is supposed
to sell I think over 300,000 copies are
you ready for the next level of
superstardom no I think I am honestly
you know I think I I feel like
I think i'm keiko always happen a little
bit without really realizing it your
destiny as predicted the album debuted
at number one and exceeded sales
expectations selling over 300,000 copies
in its first week the entire record is
produced by her older brother Phineas
and Billy told et in September how
special it is to share this huge moment
of success together he's my best friend
so it's like it's just good all the time
it's crazy good to two round together
and you get to collaborate and there's
no jealousy because it's like it's so
different for like we want completely
different things but we're both making
it happen yeah I'm saying so it's really
a journey pretty much before she knew
she'd score six Grammy nobs
she admitted she didn't exactly have
trophies on her mind
I still haven't thought about it I don't
think I will be on stage you know I
think it's so weird when people think
they're gonna be huge god that's so
weird I never in a million years
would've thought this would happen like
I'm only grateful for it for real fast
forward to November at the American
Music Awards Billie was officially a
Grammy nominated artist
do you feel this pride yeah it doesn't
really matter who wins it because it's
like to be even nominated at all to be
in the realm of the Grammys in any sort
of way is
like indescribable so you know I've been
watching the Grammys my entire life man
like from my whole life and it's I've
been saying and to cap off such a sweet
year in December billboard named her
their Woman of the Year it's really
weird to be a Woman of the Year at 17 I
want to thank all the women in the past
who have been the reason that I can be
the way that I am look awards are great
and all but Billy always keeps it real
it just wants to enjoy the ride where do
you see your path going like what is
your place in the music industry
I'm just hoping for the best I'm like
trying to enjoy it and like not complain
because what is there to complain about
[Music]